g
tout à fait
quoi
[Musique]
mieux il avec moi
nous on est vraiment aux indices
américains de 35 tout ce que les l'année
dernière ils ont dû rajouter des tables
dans chaque salle parce qu'il manquait
des tables on est vraiment tout le temps
tous collés et je veux dire c'est
n'importe quoi
on s'est dit on a beaucoup moins de
chances d'attraper le coville en étant
comme ça d'un tous regroupés dans un
blocus que d'être en classe comme ça on
a des toutes petites salles pour les
cours d'anglais et d'autres courses est
très gênant des toutes petites sommes on
est hyper hyper confiné et la cantine
est tout petit sans aération et on mange
sont les masques du pot c'est logique
donc nous ce qu'on demande c'est déjà un
nouveau protocole sanitaire qui
permettrait aux professeurs de
doublettes de dédoubler leur classe
deuxièmement peut-être une modification
des horaires de cantine pour permettre
d'éviter des trop gros fluhr et puis
tout simplement pas un allègement du
programme mex